uh
honey
um
whoa
happy
valentine's day my love oh thank you i
love this
what is it
it's the actual porch swing where we had
our first kiss
check it out the carvings are still on
the back from 25 years ago oh my gosh
phil hearts claire oh honey this is
gonna look so great out on our porch i
can't believe you did this it was
nothing made a few calls drove half a
day uh had campari and haggled with a
handsy gay landlord took the swing apart
loaded it in a van ran out of gas in the
desert got harassed by a shady state
trooper and drove back with a blinding
migraine but easy peasy i love it knock
knock happy valentine's day or as i call
it the best night to go to the grocery
store and here is your valentine's gift
i wrapped it myself in the office and
then like a ding-dong i left it there so
whoa sparkly just like you that's why i
picked that rock she sure did yeah
claire i think i know what this is i
can't believe you did this i know right
you got me an old watch pretty cool
right so cool i've got a crazy good
poker face but i didn't love the watch
i've been dropping these big hints about
a pair of genuine houdini handcuffs on
sale at a local magic shop they're from
his famous coffin of cobras escape of
1923.
the trick was so shocking that women
went into spontaneous labor and the men
paired off in violent fighting i uh
don't think it's working ah well i mean
i'm just seeing this watch for the first
time but it looks like it's got a
self-winder you just move your yeah arm
around to keep it going i should
probably get going mother's waiting in
the truck and she's patient until she
isn't
[Music]
oh and i've got to get to work too
before all the single gals show up it's
pretty hard to concentrate with all the
bathroom crying and the half-eaten
chocolates getting hurled at the wall
have a good one i will
oops
i seem to have dropped my spare hotel
key phil shh
no need to call whoever this phil is
you're in no danger
this key is to room 422 with the ramada
down the street slip out when you can
i'll pre-disable the smoke detector so
you don't set it off when you shimmy out
of those sensible wide leg trousers for
the past several valentines we've
adopted sexy alter egos juliana wild and
spontaneous and clive passionate
collector of beautiful women and antique
sailing maps
clive i love this idea
save that energy my dear this hotel has
a very short memory and a very long
outdoor staircase claire you have to
finish signing these contracts hey phil
hmm phil no
name's clive friend say maybe you could
take over here for a bit
i'll make sure the boss lady's back in
one piece no later than
come on hi phil it's clive actually
apparently they have a thing like how
you and your sister go to those
conventions dressed like stuffed animals
oh um claire your two o'clock is here
and you can't be late phil look i really
appreciate this i do i spoke to the
florist turns out my admirer sent these
from pritchett's closets i may have a
sad love life but i don't need my mommy
trying to boost my self-esteem and if
you really want to give me some
confidence how about a picture of me on
your desk and not just haley and luke
first of all i didn't give you those
flowers second of all there is a picture
of you hmm where is it
salutations yes hello i've got a meeting
ben you're gonna finish the contract
stuff margaret you're gonna take alex
you're gonna find out who's using our
account for flowers okay
phil
honey we'll do valentine's day later
okay do i know that guy in the cloak uh
hinge specialist you might have seen him
around he's the guy for offbeat swivels
and rare beveled hook joints i find
everything you just said very tidily
we'll make up for this later over dinner
i promise i've got it all planned
hi honey i'm sorry i'm late we had a
whole incident
at the warehouse a
paint mixer blew up luckily i had these
overalls in my office i could
oh you're mad aren't you mad
i mean was this the best valentine's day
we've ever had no was it the worst yes
i gave you a great gift i tried to
surprise you at the office you repaid
the effort by making a reservation at a
truck stop and dressing up like tom
sawyer
but hey
maybe this happens to everyone claire
romance fizzles
magic dies at least we can mark the
exact time it happened to us thanks to
my new watch which only a switchboard
operator from the 1950s could keep wound
you mean
this watch
the houdini handcuffs i've been taking
magic lessons as a valentine's surprise
wait a minute the supposed hinge
salesman at your office the great
magesto of course i didn't recognize him
without his floor-length robe covered in
question marks and we also really do
have a reservation at that really nice
place down the street so we should
probably
get your check
excuse me can we get the check
but
are you really dressed
come on honey we should get going wait
uh do you have the key
no
but you do
i don't deserve you
[Music]
you